first of all again an introduction on
what we're about specifically we are
challenging many of the interpretations
physical interpretations of mathematical
hello everyone I hope everyone's doing
as good as I am just had a little glitch
there but my video that's when I'm a
little late and first thing I want to
say is that you know I've if you can't
hear me for some reason please let me
know in the comment section I've had all
kinds of headaches this past week with
sound and some a little jittery about it
okay so please let me know if you can't
hear me you can't see me or whatever I
think I'm doing fine but I don't know
and the reason is ons is out of town
today so I got to hold down the fort all
by myself and he's usually the guy who
deals with these issues so again if you
can't hear me if you can't see me please
let me know okay and so where do we
start well first I want to mention the
we have a conference in Argentina yeah
remind people about that let me put that
up there for a second and that's a six
rational physics conference it's hosted
by Dave Robinson who proposed it be kind
of twisted my arm and convinced me to to
be his co-host ok no problem so we're
gonna do it gonna be on Saturday
November the 10th I'm gonna put out some
information next week about it so stay
tuned if you're you know gonna
participate you're gonna go down there
ok and let me know as soon as possible
if I arrive before you do I'm gonna go
and pick you up ok so give me your
flight number and you know all that
information and I'll give you a ride you
keep in mind that's like 40 45 minutes
from the airport to the center of the
city
ok the other thing you should be aware
of is ya Hans is gonna be there ok so
all of you who some of you have already
met him
Austria well he's gonna be in there
again so if you want to talk to him
that's a good time to do it you know
you're gonna have enough time to talk
with him about about different things
okay so today I wanted to talk a little
bit about assumptions and I'm going to
talk about assumptions because you know
we've had this past week a discussion
between assumptions and axioms okay and
more or less they're defined like this
okay the axiom is taken is a statement
taken to be true without proof it's a
universal truth or postulate and an
assumption statement conceded you know
momentarily taken to be true for the
sake of argument
okay that's those are the general
notions we have of axiom and assumption
they're not exactly the same things okay
and again for those who are just popping
in I want to make sure that you can hear
me okay so let me know through the
comments section if you can't see me or
can't hear me I don't have my son Adrian
there to to help me out today okay
holding down the fort all by myself so
why do I bring up the subject of
assumptions again or you know reinforce
he get well I had a reply from Iver cat
he's a fellow who just recently began
discussion with and and the other day I
talked about in one of the videos and he
watched the video and now he gave me a
little bit of feedback and he raised the
issue of assumptions and so in that
sense it's very pertinent that you know
we've been dealing with actions and
assumptions what is rational what is
irrational
okay thanks Martin for for that work
I'm a little jittery of a little nervous
somebody probably we had with sound
especially last week but thanks for that
note anyways Iver cat you replied okay
he replied and he raises the issue of
assumption and it's so pertinent because
we were talking about us
since what an axiom is what an
assumption is what is rational and
irrational what is logical versus you
know but is rational and and also in the
process trying to lay the foundations of
physics science first and physics
specifically under that and ever cat you
know he comes up and he says the
following in his last note to me he says
you deal with the problem of assumptions
which are false ok I do wish you would
go deeper and confront assumptions which
are internally contradictory I have come
upon a number in electromagnetic theory
he came upon a couple of them and he
mentions that a couple of these he says
the assumption is the one assumption
right one one that he considers that is
is a problem ok says is that the
negative charge reaches a certain point
but under the same classical theory it
cannot reach that point Maxwell's
equations are thought to assert
something which they failed to assert ok
that's his first criticism of one
assumption made out there by a lot of
people and he he he's against that
assumption ok fine the second one an
earlier example is displacement current
which was invented because maxima and
everyone else did not notice that the
charge had to spread out across the
capacitor plate ok and he had to note he
says I do wish you would come away from
your scholasticism and address much
simpler matters in other words he feels
wasting my time with what most
mathematicians at least you know feel
our semantics they dismiss as semantics
as metaphysics the philosophy or
philosophy of science or philosophy of
physics so he dismisses that yeah I
don't want to talk about language yeah
you know grammar I want to do some some
real physics and it doesn't work that
way
it doesn't work that way I'm sorry and
and you can see this was you know I
asked him a question let me follow up on
this I asked him a question the other
day I said where do I have that here um
I think it was this one
no here this one I asked them you know I
I put these two questions him I said the
golden principle of physics is physics
requires an object yes you you can't do
physics without an ouchy yes or no and
if so which I assume every physicist
would say yes I asked him to define an
object I said you know as far as I'm
concerned object is that would shape
since he didn't answer my previous
question I put in a yes-or-no format the
second time around said is an object at
which a shape well to this day he has
not answered the question and he would
rather talk about what he considers
physics and what I consider religion I'm
saying he doesn't do physics he has no
clue whatsoever what physics is if he's
gonna talk about stuff like what he
mentions here he says and where is it uh
this one here he said the following i
underlined almost all the words but all
the key words as I see him let me move
aside a little bit here I start with
primitives or a primitive primitive what
does it mean by that it means an
undefined word he's gonna use undefined
words and again when you asked him to
define she says you are you doing
semantics you're doing philosophy and
that's where the first problem start
because if physics or science is about
explaining a theory rationally the first
thing you gotta get straight is your
language and he says I'm not gonna do
I'm not gonna define my terms I'm gonna
use undefined terms what he calls
primitives okay fine so let's continue
he says at a point and he's invoking
really Euclid's point that's the context
there is no knowledge famous word we
discussed like two weeks ago there is
no such thing as knowledge in part
because no one has ever defined the word
knowledge we don't know what knowledge
is but he used it now as I oh we all
know what knowledge is right maybe it's
justified true belief like Plato said
well he's got to do some homework on
under word knowledge he's got to do a
little background because he can't use
the word knowledge if you don't know
what knowledge means it said there is no
knowledge about the rest of the universe
at that instant instant has to do with
time again has nothing to do with
physics we don't use the word time in
any way we don't use seconds minutes
hours months years in physics that's
used in mathematics and the religion of
mathematics they use instants and that's
important to them in visit we have no
use for time for instance for seconds
none of that there might recite
something now there's the word I want to
get to
he uses the word something like if we
knew what word to the what he's talking
about but I asked him to define it I
said look something is that which has
shape and yes or no and he has not
answered that question and I want him to
ask answer that question and at that
point you know now now he's treating
point as a location he says at that
location
that's what I mean or maybe he means at
that instant at that second in time I
guess one of those two it's got to be
there right and there may be something
again the word something whatever
something is arriving at that point now
it's a I guess a location I guess the
first one could be in treated as an
instant at that instant arriving at that
location maybe that's what he means yeah
because he says at that point at that
instant so at that location at that
point so he keeps using these words like
if he knows what he's talking about okay
and that's why I want him to define
these terms because they have no meaning
whatsoever at least for the purposes of
physics we don't use the word point we
don't use the word instant we don't use
the knowledge we don't use primitives so
whatever he's talking about it doesn't
have anything at all to do with physics
got to do with religion what he does
apparently is religious all right okay
so I'm familiar
energy current traveling okay neither
current nor energy travels okay at sea
or at any speed there's no such thing as
energy and we had mr richard fineman
tell us the other day that no one knows
what energy is
they've never defined a term we don't
know what energy is that's a word
invented by the Mathemagician x' and if
they keep passing from one generation to
the other since the days of aristotle
and no one has sat down to define the
term no one knows what energy is is it a
physical object can you bring it and put
it in the middle of the conference room
and show us look this is what energy is
can you do that no you can't not with
energy you can't do it with mass you
can't do it time you can't do it force
you can't do a field you can't do it
wave can't do it plasma none of those
words belong to physics and that's why
I'm saying let's go back to square one
what is physics about does physics
require an object if so what is an
object those are the first questions of
physicists has to answer he avoided both
questions and that's offensive that is
very offensive because it means I don't
want to deal with semantics that's what
he's got in his head I know because from
experience that's what's going through
this minds is I don't want to deal with
grammar I don't want to deal with
English we don't deal with I want to
deal with with equipment I want to do
some some circuit stuff with send
electricity and and measure and come up
with equations that's what he wants to
do that's not physics it's got nothing
to do with physics okay so some of which
may pass through that point again point
what is the point I guess a location
you're talking about a location going
through a location or at that nco at
that instant so a point at that point an
incident at that instant a location at
that location I guess that's what he's
talking about gate under consideration
passed me through that point it has
energy density energy density that's
what he's talking about whatever energy
is you know and then he's talking about
density I guess
he's referring to some kind of volume or
something I don't know
not energy and again we don't know what
energy is so he can't use the word
energy until he finds it he assumes that
I know what he's talking about you know
and you got to talk to me you know when
you talk about these fancy words of
mathematics you know you got to talk to
me a little more baby like I'm think of
me as you know what what did Einstein
and Finance say you're gonna talk to if
you're gonna if you can't explain to a
barmaid you can't explain to a
ten-year-old then you don't know it well
enough or you don't know it at all and I
want you to talk to me like if I'm a
kindergartner I'm very hard of
understanding okay that's that's the
issue here so so where do we go with
this okay first I have to define science
and I do define science as rational
explanations science is not about math
science is not about describing
especially mathematically science is not
about using undefined words science is
about explaining a theory rationally in
the case of physics we use objects and
we do with causes and mechanisms what is
known typically as physical
interpretations and that's essentially
what the mathematical physicists dismiss
as oh that's philosophy that's
metaphysics that's the philosophy of
physics or however they want to
characterize that well that's what it is
physics you know in physics and let me
give you here an example let me keep
this up for a second in physics we have
to explain this we have to explain how a
magnet attracts another
among other things we have to explain
you know how a pen you know false the
floor and not to the ceiling that's what
we have to explain in physics and if
that's not part of physics then what is
that a part of I mean is is this not a
part of physics please tell me is this
not a part of physics I mean what do you
think and if this is a part of
how are we gonna include it within the
definition of physics because these
people define I mean I've seen several
definitions one of them is that physics
the physics is the study of matter and
energy that's one one definition you'll
find out there but in study in physics
we don't study religion energy is
another word for the word spirit you
know you ask Christian what is a spirit
and the guy who won't be able to define
a spirit for you he said what's the soul
that's the you know it's the salt that
you have in it so we think it's your
conscience you know they don't go with
all these synonym they can't define what
spirit is and the same happens with
mathematical physics they can't tell you
what energy is because energy is another
word for spirit fact I have a Cora
pretty popular Cora article showing that
you know physics and that energy and
spirit are synonyms so anyone using the
word energy is doing religion he's
saying there's a spirit that's all he's
saying and until he defines the word are
shows that what it is if if it's a what
if it's an object he's asked to draw it
he's got to illustrate it and if it's a
concept he's got to define it
unambiguously so we know exactly what
the word means if he can't do either he
can't use the word
that's the rule that's the law and so
obviously you know they want to use
these words but they assume you know
what they mean but tell you you took
courses in high school you know we
discussed already what energy was there
and then again we have mr. Fineman
saying to this day we don't know what
physics says that what energy is so
don't tell me that you know I should
have taken a course in high school to
learn what energy is no you know if mr.
Fineman tells you a nobel prize Montagna
he tells you that he doesn't know what
energy is that's it that's all I need
you know I'll use his own words against
mathematical physicists so don't use the
word energy if there's no such thing as
energy okay so yeah if this is what
science is let me put this back up again
science is divided into two branches
physics and philosophy philosophy deals
with concepts reasons and purpose
they're both objective what we're doing
here is explaining in the case of
physics we have to explain a physical
mechanism something that fell to the
floor whatever your martin says if you
like and the definition of touch be zero
this is between two objects with
internal structure within turn remember
to remember something Martin that you're
asking this question in relation to what
we said yesterday and I'll take a little
detour here just to answer your question
but keep in mind that we physics doesn't
do doesn't deal with me rheology okay me
rheology deals with internal structure
what is something made out of and for
the purposes of physics at least when
when we're dealing with objects the
object is just the outer part the shell
the table is not all the atoms it's made
out of it's just the shape and so if the
finger shape touches table shape you
know again zero distance so we're
looking at the outer surface of
something that's that's the idea for
touch okay zero distance between outer
outer objects now you're I guess you're
also implying here that we have two
objects such as because they have to be
existing objects but I guess you I guess
that's where you're coming from or I'm
gonna try to guess this into your mind I
don't know if this is what you're saying
exactly but we have asked where does a
square touch a circle and I guess you
could conceive of it saying well you
know there's they meet and there's a
location or whatever comprises the
square whatever comprises a circle that
they have in common and yeah you know
what what internal structure you're
gonna talk about as far as squares and
circles and can we talk about circle
touching a square I don't know it's uh
that is a little bit of semantics it
depends on what you decide to agree upon
if you say look
I'm gonna theorize that you know that
you know squares can touch triangles and
circles you can do that and there's no
internal structure
well then scratch it Martin that's all I
can okay let me continue here with with
this because I think you're gonna like
what we're getting to here anyways I'm
saying you know what what does physics
deal with well physics the requires an
object you can't do physics without an
object and an object is that which has
shape and unless we can agree on this as
a starting point as a yeah unless we're
on the same page on this then you know
we can't we can't begin to even talk
about energy and charge and instance and
points and any of that because we still
don't know what physics is and you know
everything I read from Ivar so far is
just religion it's just you know stuff
that has nothing to do with physics and
and that's why you know it's important
for him to answer those questions now he
doesn't answer those questions he's left
me out in you know in the cold he wants
to change the subject
and I'm just gonna insist on object and
whether physics requires an object
because I don't want him using concepts
to do physics I don't want to use the
word energy I don't want him to use the
word mass I'm gonna I don't want them to
use the word force
I want them use the word field time none
of those words belong to physics I mean
I don't need time or force or field to
explain this I just need to know what
invisible object is between the two
magnets and he who says that there is no
physical object between the two magnets
is in effect introducing spirits gods
magic or
black magic maybe and that's what we
have today if you look at black hole
what is a black hole it's zero
dimensional mass what is that that's
nothing zero that mention oh no zero
volume infinite mass that's a black hole
and they do physics with this nonsense
they say look this non-existent thing
this zero that mention zero volume zero
distance zero a size zero diameter
nothingness has infinite mass and that
infinite mass throws you know planets
around or stars around swallows their
their skin you know sucks the gasses out
of them and you say well what is this
zero die menschen Elena's that does all
this magic is it a physical object or is
it an abstract mathematical concept and
we have to determine that and same yeah
you know if if a magnet attracts another
I don't need any math I don't need any
energy I don't need any mass I don't
need any time I don't need any equations
all I need to know is to be able to
explain by what mechanism mother nature
does this magic trick that's what I need
to explain that's not philosophy it's
not metaphysics called
physics and this is where we have a
problem yeah they've forgotten about
this I guess since the days of Faraday's
nobody ever did an experiment with
magnets again you know so these people
say oh yeah I've done that nice to Anna
wait can you explain it how does mother
what is the mechanism it's the old
analogy I give of the math match
magician on stage how does he do the
magic trick Bodie he goes in there he
cuts the lady in half curtains close
curtains open then the lady's alive
standing right there next to him and the
Mathemagician what is he gonna say he's
gonna say oh I know how you did the
trick he cut her in half and two pieces
he did it with 50 strokes of the saw he
did in
20 seconds is that physics no physics is
tell me how he did the trick
that's physics anybody can measure and
give you a number based on predetermined
units
that's not physics physics is tell me
how he did the trick and I want to know
how Mother Nature does this trick I want
to know how mother nature does this
trick you know here you have a pen you
let go of it I'll see if I can do it
from here you let go and it always falls
to the ground I want to know how Mother
Nature does that magic trick
I don't want your numbers I don't want
your acceleration
I don't want your mass I want to know
how she did the trick that's physics and
these people don't understand that
because they've been so brainwashed for
years and centuries and that you know we
do all these equations we measure we
create these units and we can tell you
how fast it goes how much mass it had
how much time it took they can tell you
all that stuff they can't tell you how
they how mother in each of those a magic
trick and so yes we need to define what
we mean by physics and that's where we
have a problem here you know and it
comes down to to what is the scientific
met what is science about and what is
the scientific method and it comes to
this word but the first word is
assumption what is an assumption well
you know most of you are familiar with
my own version of science rational
explanations how do you rationally
explain something you have these three
steps you have the hypothesis you have
the theory and you have the conclusions
very straight forward one step at a time
as long as you go through those steps
you're gonna be rational you're gonna
carry out a rational explanation what is
rational well that's one more time I'll
put it up there because you know people
need to hear what you know this over and
over here it is I defined really
irrational but it's the same thing
essentially if you convert a concept
into an object you're you're you have an
irrational theory if you use undefined
words energy
mass time that or you use them in
consistently throughout the dissertation
you define the word point and what did
you do you put a dot on the board you
say that's a point okay I understand
what a point it's a dot and then the guy
says no it's not about its location or
it's a number it's a you know what is it
a ordered pair that's a point a set of
numbers or whatever it's zeroed I
mention what do you mean zero them as I
see a dot so you know again all this
undefined words that's bad theory
doesn't follow from the assumptions you
know guy presents a knife and explains
the theory with the death of the victim
with poison that's irrational and you
describe mathematically and claimed to
have explained and the last one there is
you formulate a theory of physics in
terms of reasons and purposes which
actually have to do with philosophy and
not with physics and we have the case of
mr. richard fineman
who allegedly won a nobel prize in 1965
in mathematics and what did mr. Feynman
said he said you know he talked about
his aunt falling on his butt in the ice
and so he said you know he was
suggesting that this question of purpose
why did they take her to the hospital
had to do with physics no that's a
question of purpose doesn't have to do
with physics and mr. Feynman didn't
learn that in all his years in physics
then they should take remove that Nobel
Prize from him again
that's of something basic we learn in
kindergarten physics that you don't
present a question of purpose and and
presented as a question of physics okay
so once we have that we say okay how do
we present a theory well you got to
present first a hypothesis and that's
where the Assumption the word assumption
comes in assumption means you got to
make a set of assumptions they could be
what objects are involved those could be
a sum to what is light well some guys
say it's a bunch of particles that's an
assumption and I make a different
assumption I say it's mediated by a rope
that interconnects any two atoms so
that's a different assumption these are
assumptions what do we mean by
assumption something is a statement at
UK
for granted you you accept it at face
value just to understand the theory
that's founded upon it that's an
assumption and a theory physical theory
theory of physics must have the objects
define you have to you have to present
the objects first before you say any
word you said look I'm going to present
these objects you present the particle
whatever the particle is and maybe you
present you know a ball okay here's your
particle own right right there's there's
your your famous particle guide you say
this is a particle you can't do your
whole presentation use the word particle
and at the end say oh by the way a
particle is really a field and what is a
field well a field is a a probability
wave or wave of probabilities huh I
thought it was a ball all along
throughout your dissertation I thought
you were talking about a ball and turns
out you're not talking about a ball
you're talking about some abstraction my
often when I explain your high point get
to here that I am some sort of priest I
do tell them about possible and not
possible okay let me clarify that for a
second you know let me get a little
deeper and yeah you'll probably have
more questions this is what what you
find out there you say well what is a
hypothesis I thought I knew what a
hypothesis is and you know nobody in the
last 2,000 years as defined what a
hypothesis is and there are different
versions and you should be aware of that
and a hypothesis is essentially an
assumption assumption there's a
hypothesis but that's not really what
these people who mean when they say
hypothesis in fact they have different
versions here it is the first one this
was from the wikipedia says a hypothesis
is a proposed explanation for a
phenomena for a hypothesis to be a
scientific hypothesis okay I like this
one word scientific the scientific
method requires that one contestant they
test hypotheses in in the religion of
mathematics scientists generally based
scientific hypothesis on previous
observations that cannot
satisfactorily be explained with the
available scientific theories even
though the word hypothesis and theory
are often used synonymously that's where
we have a problem a scientific
hypothesis is that the same as a
scientific theory ok so let's see what
the difference is a working hypothesis
is a provisional provisionally accepted
hypothesis proposed for further research
in a process beginning with an educated
guess or thought okay he said a mouthful
let's go in more detail now so we get to
the bottom of what this word hypothesis
means here at the different versions
keeping keep keep a running log of this
here goes okay first one an object an
objective or purpose an investigative
proposal or questions that's the first
notion they have of what a hypothesis is
I mean stick my daddy the topic a little
better objectives these are all
statements I got from the literature
okay if you go through the en and you'll
find a lot of these statements objective
state the purpose or hypothesis upon
which the project is based well that's
not a theory and they're saying what is
the purpose okay will students there's
another one well students who attended
at least two years of Montessori
Preschool have better reading
comprehension abilities at the end of
first grade than those students who did
not attend preschool at all that's not a
theory that's a question that's again an
objective it's a you're asking a
question you're trying to investigate a
topic and that's the notion a.m. which
violates what we just read from the
Wikipedia Wikipedia said it's a
tentative a theory this is not a
tentative theory this is a question or
objective or purpose or whatever and
last one question our hypothesis to be
investigating a hypothesis is a testable
assertion so they have this these
notions that's the first one let's go
with the second one so so you can see
how how all these are how many notions
of the word hypothesis we have
assumption again a prediction of
testable statement at the end of her
spray there will be a difference between
the reading comprehension abilities of
children who are a tenth who attended
Montessori preschool and children who
did not attend preschool at all a
hypothesis is your question in statement
form for example Sargassum insurer will
have fewer organisms than Sargassum off
shore that's that's like it's not a
theory if the guy is making a statement
like saying I this is this is a fact
okay that's he say you know or he's
gonna prove this fact or or he's gonna
investigate this fact he's not making a
theory okay an experiment soon
experimenters soon devises an experiment
to test the hypothesis they test
hypothesis I don't know how they test
hypothesis how do you test the theory if
the hypothesis is a tentative theory how
do you test it test that means you're
gonna prove it to someone that's what
testing means you're gonna twist her arm
you're gonna sell them a Bible that's
what testing means yeah I just want you
to explain it rationally not not to
convince me and then there's a
difference hypothesis be falsifiable
well they got that from popper right
karl popper and he says you should be
able to falsify it well I don't know in
science we don't falsify anything you
don't falsify theories what we do is we
have someone explain his theory and it
better be objective and then we come up
and we present a separate and opposing
theory if we don't agree with that
theory
so we present a separate theory we don't
falsify anything okay falsify means
you're gonna try to convince the jury
that you're right and the other guy is
wrong and we don't deal with that in
science that's they deal with any
religion and religion they try to prove
in religion they try to persuade
convince convert and recruit and you
know science we don't do that so
actually you explained objectively so
the person understands or visualizes the
theory as we said yesterday especially a
physical theory we visualize we see the
movie we say okay I understand your
mechanism what is the mechanism here I'm
saying you know there are threads moving
around did I try to convince you well if
I did I was doing religion
and we all do a little bit of religion
no doubt about we try to convince and
persuade but we should recognize that
part of the dissertation as being
religion that's opinion that's trying to
convince you trying to convert you the
the scientific part is the objective
part where I said look this is the
mechanism it's like if I explain to you
how a car works you know I'm not gonna
go in there and say look you better
believe that this is the way a car works
no I say look this the way a car works
for all I know I could be wrong
you know I explained that angels move
the wheels around the car you say well I
don't like your theory but you know I
was in here to try to convince you I'm
saying that's how I think that's my
theory of how a car works and you say
well I don't believe it Yeah right
I don't care that's not that's not part
of science that part is religious belief
and okay so let's go with another one
here this before that hypothesis becomes
a theory against high hypothesis somehow
move Moore's into a theory we must test
that hypothesis if when to prove the
hypothesis they're proving also testing
I don't know verifying it would no
longer be a hypothesis so if you prove
the hypothesis it becomes a theory and
if you prove the theory it becomes a
fact I guess you know that's the way
they do it in religion and in the
religion of mathematics when a
hypothesis fails to give correct results
it is revised or rejected and replaced
well you know they can reject all the
hypotheses they want but I mean again
this title there is a prediction or
testable statement is a prediction the
same thing as a theory that's the
question we should ask I mean I you know
are these words synonyms if I say
describe something is that the same
thing as prediction is that the same
thing as explanation is that the same
thing as an assumption is that the same
thing as a testable statement or
objective or study proposal or any of
those are those all synonyms is a
hypothesis everything and you see where
we're having a problem these people have
never defined in a precise manner what a
hypothesis is here
another one probably the most popular
one an explanation
this hypothesis explains
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
a hypothesis is an explanation lino
there was some evidence and testing
behind it some evidence they but as
evidence evidence is what the prosecutor
uses to try to persuade the jury so
that's what that's what evidence is we
don't use evidence in science evidence
is you know when the guy comes to your
door with a Bible on hand you let me
show you some evidence he's trying to
prove to you that God exists right so he
says look here's the evidence look at
what God wrote oh no kid so you trying
to prove God and God wrote the Bible
he's the author of the Bible okay it
makes sense right it's a circular
argument and then the other one proposed
explanation for a phenomenon and again
you can have you know all these
statements are from different people on
the internet and you'll find them just
about everywhere you'll find them in
books and so on and the final one which
is along those same lines it's a theory
that's what a hypothesis is any physical
theory is always provisional in the
sense that is only a hypothesis so
that's what a hypothesis is a
provisional theory that's what they call
or tentative theory as the next
statement says next one hypothesis an
explanation accounting for a set of
facts that can be tested by further
investigation equal theory what is a
theory an assumption or guess based on
limited knowledge or information but has
it bad equal hypothesis that's the
statement they put you know in I think
in a book I don't really know I've got
all these references in in different
places next to if the experiment here
bear out if the experiments bear out the
hypothesis it may come to be regarded as
a theory of law nature in theory is a
hypothesis that has been experimentally
tested and pretty soundly confirmed a
law is a law here we have the fact the
law you know proof a laws a theory so
well confirmed confirmed to who and so
why the accept that that no reputable
scientists doubts its truth I mean you
know are we talking about the theory of
you got creating the universe is
that the theory we're talking about has
that been proven I mean you know most
people believe it's so widely accepted
we should you know believe that the
theory that God created the universe is
correct because we're gonna base it on
you know everybody raising their hands
and determining that you know through
democracy through majority vote 50% plus
one that's a proven theory it's a fact
that's the way these people reason they
say that's that's the way we do science
okay so we have a problem with all these
notions of a hypothesis what is Bill's
version of hypothesis okay here we go
theory remember scientific theory has
the purpose of it is to explain explain
rationally very important word
rationally and again I just showed you a
couple criteria there so you begin with
a hypothesis and then you work towards a
theory what is a hypothesis here it is
concisely the exhibits the objects and
here were talking about physics the
objects that you're gonna use to do your
theory to explain your theory with there
better be objects because you're gonna
make a movie of this what do you have
put in each frame another other film you
got to put some shape some object in
there are you gonna do with nothing are
you gonna do it with energy what are you
gonna put the word energy what are you
gonna do the word time is that what
you're gonna put up there you gonna put
the word mass oh you got put some kind
of object and you know you have Newton
he said mass times mass divided by
distance Square well you know you mass
well wonder he's talking about a cat and
a dog and he says yeah but he can't put
cat and dog in his equation you can't
put the word cat here and the word dog
there divided by distance square or
separated by distance that you know
that's unmask matically mathematical so
what does he do he says no you take the
mass you gotta weigh the cat and find
out how much mass he's got you do it
through weight right there's no
difference between mass and weight
absolutely none by the way you've gained
I've discussed that in the past and you
take the the dog you weigh him so you
say okay anyways uh this guy
weighs 10 kilograms this one get weighs
5 kilograms so you got 5 kilograms 10
kilograms you multiplied and divided by
the distance and you get the factor down
times the gravitational constant gene
you get the force so is that physics and
again they can't put a cat and a dog in
there that's why they don't deal with
objects in mathematics they deal with
these abstract concepts they created but
then they forget about the object they
forget about the elephant and the ant
and they start doing physics quotations
with mass or with energy or with force
or field or whatever and when you they
come across the guy like me and says not
oh don't talk to me about all that
gibberish that you people talk over
there at the math asylum talk to me in
plain English talk to me about dogs and
cats that's what I want to deal with I
deal with dogs cats trees rocks houses
tables chairs that's what I deal with I
deal with objects you can't do physics
without an object so though I'm talking
to me in these abstract notions and and
that brings us to what mr. Bourne said
in the 1920s that physics has become
more and more abstract it turns out that
the word abstract is the opposite of the
word physical and abstraction is the
opposite of physical they're gonna do
abstraction called abstraction don't
call it physics physics deals with the
physical abstract deals with the
abstractions so don't cut physics if
you're doing math you're doing
abstractions and you try to convince me
you're doing religion period okay so we
start with the exhibits we show the
objects that we're gonna use for a
physical theory now we have to define
our terms what is an object or what are
the crucial words and I'm saying for
physics you need certain words that form
the foundations of physics you need to
know what an object is or the word
object means you need to know what
distance is location motion and exist
those five words you need to define you
haven't even those words you're not a
physicist you're not doing visit if you
have cannot define those words
unambiguously
okay other biggest see rigorously
precisely so that you can use them
consider
stop me you're not doing physics you're
not even doing science you're you're
doing some other religion and so you
need definitions and again those five
words are you need to define what an
object is we can't do physically without
an object you need to know what location
what distance is between two objects you
need to know location set up distances
you need to know what motion is two or
more locations and you need to know what
exists means object that has location
and that's your starting point now you
can deal with these words rationally cuz
you can do them scientifically you can
use them consistently and then the third
item is statement of facts also known as
assumptions what are the assumptions one
other two it could be a picture it could
be a movie every movie starts with one
frame I don't know any movie that
doesn't have a first frame but if you
know of one please send me the link I'd
like to watch it I'd like to watch a
film that doesn't have a first frame and
a theory is a film in a theory of
physics is a film that's got all these
objects in it all these images I got
watch something I can't watch nothing
and say oh what a great movie that was I
can't watch energy and mass and and
fields what are they gonna put for these
words what are they gonna put on the
board they're gonna put some shape well
that's an object what are you gonna put
in there you have put an elephant dog
cat what are you gonna put up there so
yeah you need to make a film of your
theory that's a theory of physics it's a
film of objects in motion that's what it
is and you start with one frame that's
gonna be your assumption your starting
point and you could also say that a
series of frames is your starting point
you're telling you a little story you
know if there were like I mentioned you
know someone got killed with a knife
stuff good to her back well you can
present to the court right you say look
this is the snapshot I found I found the
person on the floor knife stuck to her
back she was facing down she had blood
coming out you this
Travie see that's one way of doing it
and another one is to use like we
discussed yesterday you take a theory
from someone else and you use that as an
assumption you say let us assume that
for example a light consists of a flow
of particles so you don't really present
a photograph you say look this is my
starting point this is what I'm gonna
call light and you show a flow of
particles you show a few frames you say
this is light this is gonna be light for
the purposes of my theory so that you
can follow my theory does this mean that
light does in fact consist of the flow
of particles now it just means that for
the purposes of understanding the
presenters theory
you're gonna concede you know the
hypothesis the assumption of the sets of
frames there and you say okay I see what
you're what you mean every time you say
light I know what you're referring to
you're referring to all these little
flow particles or you could do it
without a trace you say look it's a flow
of electrons whatever it is you call
that current say I'm gonna use the word
current okay what does it mean it means
you know flow particle you show the
little movie the little film strip and
say this is a flow of particles I'm
gonna cost current fine then you're
gonna use the word because now you
identified what you're talking about
when you're saying current but these
people talk about current and then going
immediately into numbers they go into
coulombs or you know whatever intensity
and amps and so on no no that's we don't
deal with that stuff I want to know what
little physical thing is going on inside
a cable that's what I want to know
that's what I want to understand I need
to understand that in order to
understand your theory you can't just
skip over that step and say well we all
know what eletricity is no I don't
please tell me that's the way it works
at least that's where it works in
science okay and so yeah I've got a
problem with with what I received from
mr. cat because you know he didn't he
hasn't started to talk about physics and
I'll put his statement up again one more
time
where was it here yeah here it is
you deal with assumption he gives to
example I'll just put this a little
lower here the assumption that negative
charges reach a certain point the second
one displacement current oh we don't
recognize the word charge we don't
recognize the word current what is he
talking about okay
and he hasn't defined a point he thinks
we understand what a point is you know
he takes it for granted and you know he
hasn't told us what a point is he says
oh it's a it's a primitive it's an
undefined word you know so so again you
know we're still not in the realm of
physics okay we're not in we were not in
the realm of physics in order to start
with physics you have to tell me what do
you mean by physics let's start at
square one
let's see raise the board and begin with
square one because we don't were not on
the same page we're down a st. P he
comes with a lot of words that have no
meaning for me in which I reject
completely as words of religion and so
so you know he can't come in there with
these words and try to stick them like
in my mouth like saying look look at my
equation look at look at the current the
look at instant look at point I don't
recognize any of those words so he's
talking gibberish I need for him to say
start what is physics about and he
doesn't want to answer that question he
doesn't want to say yes to a very
straightforward question is physics
about objects do we need an object to do
physics and he skips around he I mean
it's a yes-or-no question I mean it's
very easy why doesn't he answer that
query it's uh we need objects and
physics why does he say that because
he's not gonna use objects he's gonna be
using concepts and he's gonna treat up
like objects and that's where we're
worried he's gonna be doing religion not
physics that's why we need to establish
what physics is and then you know he if
we're gonna say okay if physics requires
an object done what is an object and yes
we have to establish those foundations
before we begin
any discussion of physics and if it's
too tedious you contacted the wrong man
because we need to cover those that I'm
not gonna go with Newton anything from
Newton to Hawking is dead it's worthless
garbage 400 years lost completely we
haven't been doing science or physics
and people said well look at all the
technology we have technology has
nothing to do a sign science is about
explaining technology is about
developing devices so don't tell me that
we have quantum computers and we have
GPS because the science you know quantum
is correct and relativity is correct no
it doesn't work that way we look at the
explanation that comes out of quantum
and we look at the explanations that
come out of relativity and they're
irrational if they're irrational where
do we put them well here is that the
definition of science it's very clear
where we're going to put them we're
gonna put them under religion we're
gonna put them on the right hand side
where we have opinions and beliefs
that's what religion is and we have
supernatural theories which includes
Christianity Islam Judaism mythology
astrology alchemy and all that sub and
then we have irrational theories
mathematical physics general relativity
quantum mechanics string theory oh that
is irrational why is it irrational
because they're using concepts as
objects that's essentially the main one
but then you have you know undefined
words and you know their theories don't
follow from their hypothesis and so on
and what's the difference between a
rational and supernatural supernatural
is something you can imagine you know in
other words you can you can imagine God
right you can put God on the screen you
put a bearded man with a magic wand and
that's God parody you're done you want
to put an angel not a problem you put a
man with wings and a little plate on his
head and that's that's an angel so I can
I can illustrate supernatural theories
I cannot illustrate irrational theories
I cannot the assumptions I cannot Allah
straight four-dimensional space-time
I cannot illustrate zero dimensional
point or a particle I cannot make a
picture I cannot pick a make a snapshot
or bring a picture of or draw a field
there's no such thing as field there's
no such thing as waves there's no such
thing as energy there's no such thing as
mass there's no such thing as time I
cannot put any of these in pictorial
format and if and that's why it's an
irrational theory if it's based on those
words and that's what mathematical
physics does
that's why anything related to
mathematical physics anything that's got
to do with the quays and then so and
that goes into you know on the right
hand side in religion we don't use
mathematics to explain any phenomena of
nature so please don't don't bring
equations we don't deal with equations
in physics and physics we have to
explain this and for this there is only
one way and that's identifying the
invisible mediator what is on an
invisible mediator we have the big
experiment yesterday did I do that with
magic did I do it with energy did I do
have a mass no I did it with air and
what is the area well you can
hypothesize whatever you want you can
say look there's a bunch of particles ok
fine so a lot of particles you bloom out
of your mouth and push the paper we all
understand the theory whether you
believe it or not that's a separate
issue but I understand your theory at
least because you used object you use
your mouth you use the particles called
air and with that you pushed the paper
it's self-explanatory a baby can
understand that but when yeah when we
come here they get lost they say oh but
it's not air that's stringing them
together ok so what is by what mechanism
does Mother Nature does to do this magic
trick is there nothing between these two
magnets nothing at all
oh I can't see anything I couldn't see
the air either does that mean there's no
air because I can't see it I can't smell
it or or touch her or hear it so there's
nothing here I mean we talked about the
field and they never tell you what they
mean by field what is that physical
object that's in there that does field
because field is a verb field is
something in motion it's like James
Maxwell called aces field is matter
in motion he doesn't know what kind of
matter but some kind of matter that he
can't see and we gotten away from now we
said well there's no matter that we
can't figure that out so let's forget
about that
Oh physics you need to define you need
to determine what physical object is in
here
so there is something there in between
these two magnets and the fact that you
know when I turn them around and you
push each other away you can see I can't
there's something there something is
preventing these two magnets from coming
together you know there's some barrier
there is there nothing feel there's
nothing and so yeah the physics is done
with objects and the problem guy here
with mr. cat is that he wants avoid
talking about objects and of course he's
not gonna define the word object or
concede that an objects that was
has--she so if he doesn't define an
object but then he uses the word what
was it something or was it uh here it is
where is it here it is he says there may
be something arriving at that point so
the use of the word something what do
you mean something I thought physics
doesn't deal with some things uh what is
the deal with fields what arrived that
what is that something that arrived
there a field energy mass would arrived
there so you gotta identify you know is
it an elephant to the right there is
that what we're talking about is that
that's something you're talking about so
yeah we have to define the word
something we have to define the word
thing we have to define what an object
is for the purposes of physics and you
won't find that we're defining any
textbook of physics since the beginning
of the Christian era
so assumptions okay keep that in mind
assumptions are the hypothesis and form
part of the hypothesis you have the
objects that you're also assuming
remember the objects and the definitions
are assumptions also so hypothesis means
assumptions that's what it means
essentially you know and you're also
talking about first few frames of the
film or you're talking about you know
the first picture if that's what you're
gonna describe but all that forms part
of the hypothesis otherwise known as the
assumptions then you have the
explanation the theory that comes based
on that that's it and that's what an
assumption is and he says my assumptions
are irrational but he did not identify
what assumptions are or he used a
different word where was it
uh here no here it is he used this he
says he says the assumptions that he
says you deal with a problem of
assumptions which are false you say my
assumptions are false
yes in my suit positions are false
what does he mean by that false I mean
you can say they're irrational false
just means he doesn't agree with him but
irrational is a different matter
irrational is objective it stands alone
you know he has irrational assumptions
he uses the word point he doesn't define
it
he uses the word instant he has no idea
what instant it means he's at the word
energy it's never been defined so he has
irrational assumption but if he's gonna
use energy traveling through a point as
he says how can energy travel through a
point of energy is not a physical object
you can say your cat travels through a
point you can do that you can say a rock
go through a point but you can't say
energy goes to a point because then you
made an irrational statement because
energy is a concept and if it's not a
concept draw it make a picture of it and
show us what you're talking about when
what you're talking about when you say
energy whether you repaint to it say
this is energy this this cloud of smoke
that's energy
okay anyways I thought I'd mention that
because it kind of summarizes
synthesizes what we've been talking
about essentially for the last two weeks
you know which is laying the foundations
for physics what is physics about and
you know laying the foundation
specifically means defining the key
words that we're gonna use in fish that
we absolutely need and physics and only
with those can you start putting them
into the assumptions because you're
substance are gonna move the objects
definitions any initial C internal
structure aching word and I post
questions you can post them you can post
them in patreon if you go to the patreon
page you know the rational science if
you go to the patreon page you can you
you can't hear me
can hear me fine
something happened the Salian hey Harry
I have no idea what could happen I
really it drives me nuts that I'm having
problems with Oh son I don't even know
what the touch anymore
okay then I'll have to cut it all I can
say if you can hear me go to the patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
[Applause]